i can't even sit like this that's a very
different i mean you're sitting like a
bad [ __ ] right now
it's a good day man
this is the way it should be i love it
like you waiting for humpty dumpty to
show up oh yeah you that gravy though oh
self-checkout
[Music]
my card again uh
the air got out of the tire
really you got a flat tire
not flat but you still twerking that
jeep around here the air got out is it
is the jeep here is it a truck what do
you mean the air got out
the air was in there was in there
and that was not in here i didn't do it
you know what i'm saying probably who
knows a couple brothers probably popped
in and copped the sick that's fair you
know and with all the crime going on
this is a great day it was a smash and
grab for the air smash
air out of his tires it was an air
smashing grab somebody got it i'm happy
just looking at this
this is beautiful man memories look at
this
boys
this is the way it's supposed to be guys
what's up we're looking forward to oh
man can we can we chill can we end the
hate can we end the hate are you happy
yeah i know yeah
i wanted
[Music]
he wants to be like an assistant coach
yeah yeah no he's a man no no no no but
he wanted to be an assistant coach but
still be like this uh put in steve yeah
no i have no business hey can't coach is
like i thought i was the head coach
he's like the gm sitting on the bench
yeah
i like sitting by steve no no he's just
the way he just wants to get his hands
up
on the bench you got to walk over every
now and then so you can kind of touch it
yeah i respect it's respect i respect
that this is what i respect i don't know
if that's what god wanted you know god
wants steel's hands on that body though
i'm supposed to be a coy baby oh yeah
whatever you want buddy i got nothing
nothing but respect
yeah
dude
i want to lawn mow that bok choy damn
you feel me
this bok choy oh yeah oh damn dawg i got
hair whoa
manscape you got that little shark tooth
bro you want to see it should i show it
did i show it i don't i think we're
i have seen bobby's one too many times
i'm all sad though yeah yeah yeah there
you go we get it man there you go
yeah no one looks like yeah you're
brothers
i heard it doesn't take really long to
see it if you look at it
you might miss it
all right now you're really starting to
piss me off yeah
just what you wanted this is what you
wanted me over here
a little different now that he's you
know doing stand up uh what two weeks in
don't start that two weeks
i don't know what i'm doing i was scared
as hell up there i was frightened and
i'm just like okay look he's more sober
than his brother dude yeah so
time stamp
what
this dude got a problem
for real have you talked to my brother
bob will not respond to my calls or
attacks [ __ ] ever since he sent that
snake
i don't know he's probably worried about
that the repercussions you've tried
reaching out to him
yes have you been speaking to him you
don't talk yeah i don't know he always
gets back to me like when you uh did a
set at the high i said hey man i'm
telling you stevie did well you can do
this man he put awesome thumbs up you
said that to him yeah yeah
i got your daughter
i don't know how you all do it but it's
it's so frightening the the adrenaline i
don't know how you guys managed to
compose yourself that's what it is man
especially you guys doing specials i
don't know how you the hell you guys do
that
it's insane i mean eric been doing for
40 years still been here for about 27
yeah eric used to do it at the damn mom
here we go
[Music]
eric you have to follow charlie chaplin
that's the first time you've done that
my wrestling you don't know about my
wrestling that's what it is you're mad
you're here with me bro
that's what i said it feels so beta over
here i told you not to use that word
makes me aggressive stevie
that's how i was in seattle i was just
surrounded by soy boys i want to grab
people how was that it looked good yeah
what were you doing i was at a theater
in everett which is like 30 minutes
outside it's the oldest theater 30
minutes outside of what seattle the main
the main oh yeah the capitol there you
know what i'm saying oh yeah but uh it's
three minutes outside this theater so
goddamn oh they had pictures for reals
charlie chaplin like 1904
that's it yeah they had white dudes and
blackface pictures
and i said you know because my whole
crew chappelle david all black i go we
walk down we get in the green room and
there's white dudes with black face i go
god damn i started laughing oh god how
the who the [ __ ] leaves what's up
because this is history man yeah they
got all this history all right
history's history man with the tough
part is if you're a kid nowadays and you
are a fan of a black athlete and you
don't know anything about that [ __ ] yeah
you can't
dress up like you're black athlete like
if you're i feel like if you tell a kid
like you can't like a little white kid
or a little maybe
uh
light
chinese or something
tell them korean whatever you get
offended by that no you have to ask
yourself like what context what yeah
context but what do you want kids to
uh remember and know i mean like so the
past generation
it's deep
it's seeped in racism and hate and all
the things that it represents to them
but if you're a kid today you know you
know if you're 15 years old right now or
even if you're 20 years old there was
eight years of your life where there was
a black president you know things are
different
and so you don't look at it that way but
the problem is the older generation
still holds on to it yeah so it's like
at one point so i'm on either side
because at what point you go you don't
want to forget history but at the same
time you want we want to move on yeah
you know yeah it might just take one
more generation yeah because then you
could have a kid if he's a rough person
in that black kid
russell wilson and it's not like that
you don't have a grandparent in the
distance whose blood pressure going to
go yeah but if you want to be russell
wilson you just wear a number three
jersey do you have to paint your face
that's how i that's how i hustled my mom
me and my brother time i was wearing
kids you know we love jerseys mom were
like where you guys want to be for yeah
i still love jerseys
i have rock'em all the time baseball
usually wagon
aaron rodgers yeah yeah he's my lord and
savior anyways uh anybody they're born
you know what i'm talking about
they're looking good
they're gonna go to the super bowl i
tell my mom i won't be junior sale for
halloween so she'd buy me a jersey dude
the packers are like aaron rodgers mood
ring it's basically however he's kind of
feeling that 100 that's how the team
yeah
that team riding dies with him but he
balls and they still suck sometimes
sometimes you guys ready to get in the
show sure yeah
have more catching up to do
they're talking about football we don't
die
i want to know how that's from
thanksgiving i want to know what you
know what has been up to man this is
special
with you i had dishes for you guys you
didn't give me an address
from the racist stuff man remember
typical honky right here
[ __ ] clean ass chill i'm sorry we got
forks
i'm sorry we're gonna eat with our hands
children
you had some good food i was all right
it was just all right
you had gourmet [ __ ]
[ __ ] before you were talking about like
i'm making my special great
i just went to k-town with bob oh
what kind of so what kind of k-town
thanksgiving augustine
you've been there oh yeah you guys went
to korean barbecue for thanksgiving yeah
that's the thing y'all gonna come all
the way over here and then not even
freaking do like to do
still vote democrat in texas you can't
go to staples center bruh for the laker
game and play video games dude i don't
like what's going on
what's wrong with korean food on
thanksgiving man nothing that's all i
understand but you can have that every
other day yeah you can dip yourself all
day you do that you can dip your chicken
easter you hide in eggs you're not
hiding
invited to
did i not invite everybody on when we
were in here last night
wasn't officially
kind of
speak up
what he invited me to thank you you knew
the address yeah i know that theo is out
of town fuel usually comes by
people replace me with kid rock
kid rock was there how was kid rock's
thanksgiving i didn't go to kid rock you
went to kid rocks thanksgiving that's
that's news to me it's all it's it's the
only place i've ever been where it's all
white meat is it like
was it like django and change people
fighting
they even died that's the entertainment
yeah that's the two black guys they were
just fighting
kid rock this one my favorite hair man
yeah dude you did you went to kid rocks
no i did not he always he hangs out i
give him [ __ ] oh i drove down out i
drove down to alabama man and that was
uh
it was it was a nice time but it was
definitely pretty low-key people was
pilled up i put it on my insulin why did
you drive down tick-tock were you doing
shows huh
i was down there with uh no i just drove
down there to do things are they gonna
give you like your own street like theo
lane still feel like right through a
trailer park you know what i mean well
here's the thing that happens a lot of
times in a lot of rural areas you get
people they buy the land and then they
build the street so they pay for the
street this is what i was doing right
here this is what's going on with it yes
pillow fighting
when it starts over i'll put volume oh
it's smoking you smoke that turkey too
much
there's smoke in here smoke all over i'm
going to the hampton inn you creeps
it's 8 o'clock y'all are on pills and we
haven't eaten pills
and i like how they dress up
i want to see his family no play it
again i want to see his face his little
cousin had on his good shorts wow
he got his thanksgiving shorts i'm sure
he's super short and that's the indian
tradition he's doing right there both of
them
native american tradition bro
man eight o'clock we hadn't eaten till
eight o'clock damn
that's my mind bro [ __ ] white people
man yeah that's dinner
typical [ __ ] hey man if you got a
special gal
or man people are gay yeah dog yeah bro
for you dude if you got a special dude
in your life you give him that diamond
ring diamond earring whatever it is dude
i've already got the diamond poirier in
my life
coming up
but i mean he's a great guy yeah i see
what you're saying blue nile blue nile
they got everyday fine jewelry we
talking diamond jewelry cocktail rings
tennis bracelets oh we got all sorts of
jewelry for your girlfriend your wife
your husband your aunt and look the
world step mom oh everything stepmom
friend
ex-friend yup yeah oh someone you're in
a lawsuit with walk across that aisle in
the courtroom huh hit him with that
tennis bracelet change the game yep
change the attitude man here's what i'm
saying is this man the world is ending
so you might as well go out with some
something dimed out on your own your
neck or wrist dude fly when the world
ends dawg look flexion look at the
egyptians look how they did it
make the season shine with jewelry from
blue nile.com
shop this week take advantage of the
cyber week sale
with select jewelry up to 50 50
plus now through christmas enjoy free
two-day shipping and as always blue nile
order is insured ships free and arrives
in discrete
packaging that won't give away what's
inside shop stress free find your
forever peace
go to
bluenile.com today
yes
um it's holiday man i know it is you
keep saying packages going everywhere
you got your merch whatever you got to
get ship station
shipstation.com dog sell anything online
i don't care what it is the other day i
had some i was i didn't know what to do
with it i'm like oh man i got this thing
it was like a blender that i used to use
but my uh the power went out of my
building so yeah i'm like i gotta get
this just
somebody that could use it sure so
i'm like how do i get it there though i
didn't know what to do and i was just
gonna arrive on time well i was just
standing outside with it man you need
ship station man you need ship station
because they work with all major
carriers international local including
fedex usps ups dude we got you covered
really it's super easy no wonder 90 of
companies that use shipstation for a
year two isn't it dude name them they
use them and make holiday season a
little brighter with ship station use
the code kats to get a 60 day free trial
just enough time to handle that holiday
rush
just go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone top of the page enter the
code k-a-t-s ship station make ship
happen yeah amen baby mail me that
percocet fam
what'd you do eric
well i actually wasn't feeling well so
we were gonna go to rachel's parents and
then like i got like a sinus infection
yeah they're innocent you got that new
variant you got the news
and you know it's funny you say that
because i i had i took like three covet
tests like just to make sure because i
was like oh no what you know i was like
i finally got it but now it's called
allergies yeah
it was like i i've always had sinus
infections so we ended up just going to
um what is it uh del frisco's in century
city
a lot of mixed species not to say this
but if you're a mixed species you're
more likely to get uh let's start the
show
when you cross breasts no you get more
different type of uh genetic infections
yes it's like bull terriers yeah yeah
like the white bull tears always happen
you gonna co-sign this man
that's right man thank you you guys this
is why we had to separate them steve
and look at him
over here
you act like you fool something don't
you got some i mean 23 of me says i am
yeah
look at this man british dude he's this
strong
they did it brother british oh yeah
everyone hates winners
they're the ones i like
tongue sweat a little oh i remember
splitting mckenzie seeing all these pups
yeah oh
yeah that was a dog's reference by the
way that was not man
you've ever been a pet owner
yeah i know i had a chihuahua what
happened though
you want me to really tell you i mean
it's not a good story i'd love to hear
it well my dad had a gnarly stroke
my mom calls me up three four in the
morning oh his time his time it calls my
brother up and bob's like dude i'll pick
you up in 15 minutes dude just get ready
pack and i go all right well let me pack
my stuff and then let me get dolly's
stuff dolly was my chihuahua he's like
you're not bringing dolly no you can't
bring a dog
what do you mean you're not bringing
dolly yeah fair point let him talk to
you and so he we had to drop her we had
to drop dolly off at uh
the uh shelter we'd have to get rid of
her you could have just left her in the
water it was three or four in the
morning i didn't want to like just drop
i didn't give away
forever god dawg wow the little
adversities like you see uh they cold
blooded god damn hey stevie bob calls
the hey dad has a stroke sell the dog no
let me let me add to it dolly always
tried to bite his ankle like dolly
didn't like a bite he could chew on him
now he's stroked out
you know what i'm saying
that i'm doing this time
bob's it bob dolly never liked bob yeah
never liked bob bob's a bully so he made
you get rid of your dog yeah wow keep it
in though i changed my mind keep it in
yeah yeah what is that it's like a book
drop at the library yeah nobody's
working there was just like like you'd
leave a baby
it was a bad bad day it was a really bad
day because i thought my dad was gonna
die too on twitter you're going to take
two l's yeah
yeah
i felt so guilty i was looking for her
on the website i was like you know i was
going through the profiles of the dogs
looking for dolly i felt kill like i was
thinking wait you should maybe bob just
meant you can't bring the dogs leave it
at home
and you took that ass well we gotta give
it away no no no no no no no no no you
didn't mean that
i know i don't i know what you're doing
right now
i know what he's doing right
now i know what you're doing right now i
know exactly what you're doing right now
you're doing you're you're you're you're
trying to hey stevie this makes me out
like the bad guy stevie
no not the bad guys i can't help it
brothers
it was bob's decision and he's like
you're definitely no get we're getting
ready no
this is my thing though you guys are
going to rush to the hospital and you
went hold on let's stop by the pound so
i can drop the dog off yes
that was his idea jim you've been silent
the whole goddamn podcast enjoying the
uh background dude silence is uh yeah
whatever it's called racism no joining
in uh no against violence is violence my
bad no but in bob's defense he felt
guilty afterwards he didn't apologize
people are basically [ __ ] violent
[ __ ] ms
you're like
if you're immune you're ms you're just a
killer
like helen keller was a bad [ __ ]
she was just like all right
man i'm glad everybody had a decent
thanksgiving man would i get tired of
having this little
this one might trigger stevie it's it's
about something we talked about recently
but
stevie cover your dick hi my name is
janet
and i have a
club for you guys
when you go to the grocery store do you
like to do
the self checkout
or um go to a cashier
me personally i like to do the self
checkout so let me know what you guys
miss independent um
[Laughter]
okay we get 30 seconds with a girl and
you gotta say something
is this the hottest chick that's ever
been on the screen she's out there she's
up there and what'd you even say i said
miss independent because she's doing
herself dog is this a model is this her
no theo called said she was a bot oh
that's a real thing is that what the sex
robots are looking like now yeah you
best believe that
they are almost there
why did you stare at me just now
what do you said sex robot why did you
stare because you best believe
because what you're thinking is steve's
gonna get one don't look at him no i was
assuming steve already has one i can't
even sit like this that's very dumb i
mean you sitting like a bad [ __ ] right
now
i mean it's a good day man he's here
this is the way it should be i love it
like you waiting for humpty dumpty to
show up oh yeah you that gravy though oh
self checkout
here's my thing is nowadays the guy
working a little the the uh the person
working the um human checkout yeah
they behind the glass they got an
umbrella yeah wearing all this m95
in in uh you know n50 or whatever they
got it all on shoulder pads they little
if i'm coming to that person they better
they're gonna have to do more yeah do
some work you better be butt naked right
behind that thing you better have your
mouth open you better be ready to catch
cove but i think because otherwise
you're gonna you're about to lose your
job to the computer man yep you bout to
leave mix it up i don't like i i can't
stand
that self-checkout [ __ ] it's because
they make it so complicated too it's
like you know
you get to scan it and then you got to
put it on the thing then it'll be like
put it in the bag or you know it's all
and then there's still somebody there
that's supposed to help you and they're
never they're not they're no help but
then also when you go like whole foods
and you do the regular checkout like do
you need a bag no [ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ]
i'm gonna carry all this for 19 products
yeah just give me the bag of course i
need a bag just charge me but no they
got the guy but you and he can't even
hand you the stuff anymore you can't
even give him the stuff yeah so he can't
even check there's no way to even you
got to throw it over the wall they got
that strong [ __ ] back it's like berlin
yeah oh that's what you're talking about
ninja warrior person hiding in there
you don't even know it's it's just
everybody a bank teller now what's god
who the [ __ ] wants to sit in that saran
wrap
they were doing that in vegas for a
little while
they're doing that that's biden's
aquarium son that's what y'all did yep
that's what y'all get voting for these
fools man
follow the money man look at the money
they make on this thing yeah this guy
needs this guy insulin makes a lot of
money too and it's needed
you know people make a lot of money
definitely need it you know what i'm
saying you shut off insulin bruh and
thousands of brothers will die and a
half and bodybuilders and bodybuilders
dog honestly did you ever shoot that
insulin back in the day
i don't think so that's some dangerous
[ __ ] dude i bought well he would've did
it with some fentanyl oh i bought some
[ __ ] one time for my buddy i think it's
supposed to be steroids and i shot it
for probably
10 weeks it wasn't i don't know
huh did you grow tits no i kind of got a
little i remember
lightheaded
no i remember sleeping more and i
remember just
kind of not be believing a lot of stuff
no what do you mean believe in a lot of
you didn't believe stuff i just if
people were telling me stuff i wouldn't
believe them exactly i see right there
back in the day
now you just a yam y'all
[Laughter]
debate club he's in australia so he
might be in a camp right now oh no
they're super locked down
hi guys uh gaston here all the way from
melbourne australia uh cheers and hope
you're all doing well
i think it was this last clover period
um got a bit of the bait club for you
guys
just wondering
when you've done your laundry and your
time to put away like your
unmentionables like your undergarments
do you just grab them and just chuck
them in the drawer or
are you someone that likes to fold them
yeah fold them up and then neatly place
them in
and the other one likes to fold them um
spoiler alert i just chuck them in
underpants
yeah uh
let me know uh the bank club game game
buzz buzz no plus buzz bang gang bro
first of all your boy well
good to see australia man good to see
y'all still alive they love coving over
there
dude jim jeffries went there for two
weeks to do his tour in his country
really right he they quarantined him for
two weeks and on the last night they
came to him and said hey man
two people down the street got covered
you got to go back damn
box lunches in a motel room
just to get to that crowd shut it down
it shut him down they're so strict there
they love yeah they can't wait dan
hooker is getting ready for a fight in
new zealand he would have to do
underground fight camps because if they
got word that he was training at a gym
they'd shut it down oh my gosh so they
shut down like three of his camps
see i missed the old australia when
there was vigilantes yeah
yeah that was like the prison days but
yeah we sent all the criminals there
doug yeah and now they're out here they
scared a covey brother they like now one
person gets covered the whole nation
locked down yeah
but what i'm saying is if you fold in a
panty right there you gotta fold gang
baby yeah i got my
the sexual pressure
i was about to say
y'all just smashed that looks like eric
right there
[Laughter]
[Applause]
actually went to college
he would he would have done something
with himself
[Laughter]
i think everyone who tours in australia
you get off the plane you go to that
koala farm right you hold the koala
they're not right by the jets yeah some
of them know the sound of the plane go
by make them bite people yeah you gotta
fold right guys
what's up you gotta fold you gotta fold
this one when steve used to work at the
laundry so he you know you enjoy the
moment
he knows that's a little truly
that's what you get for bringing back to
the show yeah exactly remember steve had
a a laundry donut shop situation yeah
how do you do that
you really want to [ __ ] it up yeah
yeah bring back that [ __ ] high school
wrestling dog if you fold in a panty
bruh you something wrong with it yeah my
girl
girl fuzz he's like it's like so it ends
up being like straight like a wet nap
yeah you know what i mean it's like a
wet nap so i love you know
here's a here's a little thumbs up do
you ever like so
this is i don't know why i'm even saying
this please [ __ ] it bring it sometimes
like say it
where the laundry is if i see my girl's
panties i might pick it up you smell it
you try it out keep that in there
that's my life of this
episode get in there
which one hates that i'll be like at
least i'll look at her i'll be like
she's like stop it that's so nasty which
part are you smelling though well don't
they're so little it don't matter you
can just pick it up
no you know what part you smell that or
the other no i'm not taking it and going
like you know but i mean i might take a
little you know what i mean
something to get you through the night
you might put it in a bag and just give
it a little damn you're a nasty man
i love that oh i'm the only one out here
you're the only one
can't you buy used panties in japan
japan how would that national anthem go
bullseye
you got it you got your name you can buy
panties
you can buy used panties in like vending
machines yeah in japan
what's wrong with you what'd he say
yeah i'm doing that yeah but you know
the girl don't look like that yeah
i bet she looks close to it you can get
them full butt panties some old lady
making dumplings what but i'm saying how
much let's say japanese panty bin there
you go eric look at that
how do we know they're you that's your
lane right there baby you know who i
want to meet the dude who repairs those
machines
no i need the guy who feels right who
reloads them yeah
you know what he's going around
reloading them he's just getting them
from the girls they're zooming in and
the machine open i'm sure they're in
plastic zoom in still somebody's
dropping that [ __ ] off when they run low
on inventory what's the panty factory
here's how you know if you're a real
creep though do you blow out like no i
just
and then inhale real beg you to do a
quick hit or you build that with it or
do you want to do like a what is that
thing called when like i inhale and i
blow into your mouth
you do it like this me and phil go
shotgun some panties
who smelled the most used panties in
there who would it be oh that'd be a
great i'm gonna go with knitting steve
nick has a vibe i would beat everyone
here
oh yeah
yeah i just do that in my hotel room
yeah
you would see him in the machine
[Laughter]
steve steve takes the panties and he
sticks him in the black butt
for authenticity
b7 is my joint
try suzanne's medium
i can't do that
oh man i'm living there huh
oh no that's the truth well you would be
like the mr rogers
you just talk about something on the
show and all of a sudden a full gorilla
is here it's like we don't have
theo brandon stevie
eric the whole squad nick what's going
on i'm in the gym right now brandon your
boy isaiah miranda used to work here
before he went hollywood but uh respect
njc new jersey life baby but i gotta
keen it or sting it are we watching the
disney maxwell trial
or are we watching the jessie smallett
the fake
the fake white supremacist fake racist
incident or we're watching a child sex
trafficker
and uh yeah which one's more important i
don't know i think i know which one's
more important but i know the media is
going to decide otherwise so guys can
understand it that epstein side piece
hitter
or that fake white supremacist let me
know smallet case solve wait i thought
is that casey was still there
he's in court today oh he's in court
it's fine it's finally dude just that
other trial man she's naming people like
really famous people gillian maxwell's
yeah man
like i'm just like i thought i think she
mentioned like
jay-z
yeah like there's all these
co-conspirators
i saw a whole report on it but who knows
if it's real but jason is she trying to
like bring everybody down i've not
killed her yet is she gonna take the
stand she's there to stay and stand
today oh my god he got any updated
information can we watch that yeah
that's exactly what i'm saying cause
they they got rid of let's do fight
companion for the glenn maxwell trial
[Laughter]
i'll come into that [ __ ] yeah
damn she look dimed up yeah that drawer
open up the dryer you feel me sir
this is happening today the smaller
one's not that interesting but this is
more interesting
it's so many people they both got some
racial issues though because they didn't
invite any brothers to that island yeah
they did who maybe jay-z allegedly yeah
damn well small eggs he's just a dumbass
what sucks that the guy
wasn't this it sucks to who he was
because he was still a guy that was
doing a lot of business so anybody
surrounded by his business is now going
to be like in you know indicted like
like they're in his black book yeah and
there's so many names on there so many
names they found the black book yeah in
his office
there's so many so many powerful people
around crazy i feel like i feel like
let's say you're like the the the the
district the state u.s attorney general
you mean like general manager no no no
i'm saying the if you're the prosecution
the prosecution and jeffrey epstein's
lawyer goes to this guy or girl whoever
it is and says yo
um
we'll give you 500 of the most powerful
men in the entire world
that he knows if you give him immunity
yes you think they would take he would
they would have taken that deal
i think they would have taken that deal
and that's why somebody got on a phone
call and was like yo
he got to go
and they said was that sign yeah and
they were like should we make it an
accident and they were like i don't care
if you burn the prison yeah we don't
give a [ __ ] just get him out of here he
got to go yeah i i feel like that
happened no i'm sure like
it was like it could have been a texture
the stuff he had on the clintons
clinton's just everybody
clint was
she did anything with clinton though oh
well that's what we don't know why can't
they find any of these women well they
can't they are well they can't hurt
every one of them is called jane in
there they're in there yeah they're in
there man and they had the documentaries
have a few of them because the main girl
she was uh she said uh was prince
phillips
hooked up with her yeah the problem is
just like that
the royalty
documentary the nexium documentary he
had a guy on this past weekend from it
but this is the same kind of thing where
like they had people like epstein had
the girls recruiting oh yeah so the
girls so those girls themselves brought
their friends they could be in trouble
too that's what was happening with
someone because they were like you know
bringing their friends but anyway my
point is what's the next year this guy
was deaf bro and he got cured by nexium
what's the next sims story man it's that
sex cult it's like one of the worst
cults ever this guy's got 120 years in
prison alison mack was recruiting women
she's a [ __ ] monster
i just watched the last episode of the
documentary uh it's on stars she was
recruiting this she she was a she was
like
they had this thing called doss
and it was like this sex slaves but for
women oh they branded them they branded
were they underage no
they weren't under it sounds kind of lit
but
they and there you go
like that there you go damn so i think
that it is rosenbaum he did it he was
our first advice this past weekend clip
because he was on smallville with
allison mack and we got him i hit him i
just texted him
yesterday and said to him that chick's a
monster and what did he say he was like
hey that's what he's been saying you
know what i mean well here's what i want
to know if y'all got invited epstein
island yeah would y'all have gone
and steve you don't have to answer this
no not if they're like 14
steve will be there when you get off the
ship yeah yeah
like with his little hat on i'm an
island boy
cocktail shrimp
he's going around shrimp shrimp
yeah seems like ain't dipping in my
mouth
but no be honest with you if would you
if you got invited say you heard it five
years ago for any of this you hear all
these fancy people going to this island
they doing sex and they said there's a
bunch of bad [ __ ] but if they didn't
tell me if they said their legal age
it's all about these bad [ __ ] help
first class in that private jet yeah
without casey gonna be there yeah bunch
of bad [ __ ] you know
sam elliot yeah who else well you know
but they used that stuff as a way to
rope people in because even in this
nexium cult they paid the dalai lama a
million dollars to come speak right but
the dalai lama didn't know that this was
going on but it legitimized their cult
right so that's the same thing with this
epstein thing is he's you know he's this
big-time businessman and he's like yeah
let's invite jason well they would get
the most powerful
girls they know how old they are and
then they'd film it like hey you know
she was 14 dog and we got video so
you're going to play ball that's what i
think happened that's what happened like
because like you get awesome you know
she's under age you're gonna play ball
with us now because we're gonna release
this footage
that's why they did a lot of that but in
that next gem code they were collecting
collateral from the girls that's how
they that's how they made them stay
collateral meaning meaning like they the
girl would they had to take naked
pictures of themselves as blackmail they
had to tell stories about their like if
their parents were influential
any bad stuff and they would pass that
on to their like pastor it's crazy man
yeah
but here's what i'm saying is man [ __ ]
is amping up dude we got people on these
islands doing this rich people flying
out they're in outer space but rich
people aren't even on the planet basil's
trying to get out they don't realize
that [ __ ] like well there are mars on
mars huh they're on mars they're in
space they're trying to look at the news
oh my goodness yeah
yeah dude if you
close your
browser for 30 seconds yeah
he's one letter off from that
yeah you're the only person who gets
speakers in your place you could hear
the bass and porn
like you got it yeah you watch his porn
with subtitles
man god if i could buy your brother's
love for you i would
um time stamp you wanted him there
you're enabling that
but you're not you're enabling that
behavior you're enabling it
a little bit stevie yeah and i'll say
this
he was a lot more docile when i was on
the couch with him yeah he was got it
mapped out he's aggro today now you're
making sense steve now that's don't let
him come between us that's what he's
doing that's what they do
that's what they do
come to the is that that's the dark what
the hell is the dark arts anyway but the
guy that the guy the head of that next
him is he he was bad dude
yeah and they killed him no no he's in
prison for 120 years he's a he's an
appeal right now he's doing cameos also
but the heiresses what's that the liquor
heiresses they they he seduced the hell
out of them
the secret heiresses they've done
they spent like 300 million of their own
money yeah america
and [ __ ] yeah because i was watching the
documentary it's great claire bronfman
yeah there's another documentary i'll
just watch about the lady that crashed
in the lake in tennessee at the church
when have you seen that one on hbo max
no what's it called it's all about
flight it's about a weight loss church
that they have yeah a weight loss church
you go and celebrate god and lose weight
how do you do that this is a real thing
it's amazing it's interesting yeah so
you don't you don't give you too much
jesus on the uh you know what i mean
they cut it light in that crack yeah you
gotta drink too much wine you can
lighten that crack so you get you get
the white meat
[Laughter]
what else we got here steve look at you
look a little bit like a uh
sylvester stallone oh wow i like that i
like that in there i like it
i could see you doing a boxing movie
yeah stevie yeah kind of like a fireball
goes west meet sylvester stallone i love
this [ __ ]
goes east it's like rocky maybe some
maybe some muay thai five goes east and
muay thai
stevie gets his ass one no no let me win
yeah
let me win but the first couple times
it's tough yeah i love bloodsport all
those movies oh yeah yeah bloodsport
beautiful pain in the glass dude yeah
and i was working at all that's kids
and what are the [ __ ] going nuts
this guy's got one last debate club for
us and then we have some amazing flop my
hats that we got to get to well [ __ ]
what you're on it looked like chintz is
fine as [ __ ] well what shenzhen lives in
texas yo king of the sting crew what is
going on here's your boy zach from south
jersey
i got the big jersey guys in the bay
club that theo really might love
um
brian kelly head coach of notre dame
fighting irish apparently is headed to
lsu
now
i was curious how you guys feel about
brian kelly coaching
in his remaining bowl game
also
as a player
how do you feel about this coach who's
slated to leave coaching in the bowl
game as a player i'm just thinking about
[ __ ] though
yeah i'm trying to score touchdowns
[ __ ]
thanks for watching brian kelly's the
one if you're maybe you're a senior if
you're a senior or you know you're going
to go to the pros next year you don't
care you don't get funny this guy helps
it's a business decision this guy helped
you right they know but if let's say you
were recruited by him and you're like a
freshman sophomore you'd kind of be like
damn but you're allowed to enter the
transfer protocol right right so it's
like it is what it is now they get it
you know they get it they're only there
he did he's getting 10 10 years 95
million yeah from lsu yeah wow
about to be good i don't know i don't
know i know they have all the talent i
love notre dame i love the campus it's
beautiful place
it's a good place over there to get i
mean mugged but also by a dope-ass
rosary if you've ever been to mishawaka
i've never been out of indiana or um
where the campus is
um
it's a good place to get a cup of coffee
and
the kind of place you wouldn't probably
you would you donate blood you would not
accept blood there makes sense you'd be
like get me out of town before i take a
pint you know what i'm saying but what's
a bigger job notre dame lsu because
here's the thing with notre dame they
get good recruits but lsu if you recruit
right and you're in the sec you're
definitely winning well here's the
challenges notre dame the challenger
notre dame is you have to get a student
athlete
so that's a harder
right that's harder
yeah to get like that's why they haven't
won a national championship in 50 years
yeah but but they've been in the
playoffs i know but they went to the
playoffs once but
once but they got to own it but they
haven't won they they were never going
to have a chance to win so now he can go
to lsu
who just won the national championship
like three years ago and he's gonna be
able to recruit from the same recruiting
base that coach don't have to worry
about the
as much about student party like they
have sue you know notre dame these
people they have players that can read
and write they had manti teo you know
i'm saying they got asian players yeah
that's right you know imagination asians
are watching imagination yeah
yeah they got people yeah
blackfish girl remember that
his voice hurts me
he's the best dude but like schools like
stanford
notre dame cornell those kind of are
there any ideas football school but i
mean it's pretty good big red
northwestern is another one north
western yeah
it's about those schools you got to be a
student athlete it's it's more towards
student you know yeah so it's it's
that's a hardest to even that's a harder
recruiting but even though schools are
pretty loosey-goosey with academics
because miami's a private school and
yeah but i don't think i think that
notre dame has a reputation for being a
more
student athlete what is your do you
watch any sport yeah i was just thinking
i i can't add to it i don't watch
football i don't know what you guys are
talking about you only watch ufc huh no
i watch wrestling if you talk about
college wrestling yeah if you want talk
about college wrestling i could watch
college wrestling espn yeah and then
flow wrestling yeah i watched that a lot
of beautiful bouts on there beautiful
young man at night so if you guys if you
have some wrestling things i could add
to the thing i don't know only theo can
make wrestling perverted at night you
know what i mean like
he made it nasty
sniffing panties over there yeah we got
to do that it's my girl's panties though
not just yeah he's not living in a
vending machine yeah he's not a stranger
i don't know bro somebody might throw a
stranger pair of paintings dude i used
to sneak into my neighbor's own here we
go
my neighbor
my neighbor had a mom right and i would
sneak into their bathroom and hide in
that freaking uh and huff those bra cups
you hang out in the laundry hamper hang
on the laundry hamper dude yeah baby
listening to people urinating stuff and
just huffing those cups
i like trying how much yeah
bro yeah
smell those titties
[Laughter]
uh she is flaunting her aunt
damn
what happened to the first hot girl we
already left her yeah we need to go can
we go back to her
this one's hot too she's cute she looks
like a face from seven
right chin way too many little tiny bit
she's better looking at her hey king in
this thing this is marie from staten
island new york and i want to vlog man
nicole she is only 11 years older than
me and is definitely the life of the
party she is always trying to convince
me and my friends to go out with her and
at this point i think we're convinced
that she has no real friends
she doesn't like to drink but she does
love to dance even though she doesn't
know how real housewives
called the nicole drop a net
absolutely everything that she buys
which is really embarrassing and one fun
thing about her is she's still terrified
of covet she wears a mask everywhere she
goes and even if no one else is wearing
a mascara she will be that one person
still wearing her mask damn
okay
what's her name
nicole yeah you have your tits out but
then worried about catching the vid you
feel me oh mama you gotta let it loose
yeah yeah not a fan of that picture on
the left i don't know what's going on
we're on the laugh
this is terrible but the one on the
right elite sign me up we know we never
let you know she cleans up well
yeah yeah she's only 10 years older than
this one holiday this is good for her
age so she she has to be what
maybe looks like mid-24 so she gotta be
like thirty-four that's what i'm
thinking mid-thirties that means they're
looking good
[ __ ] it for a while
you know talking about your dad was 70
he was born in 18 yeah 1802 not fair
y'all doing family [ __ ] math out here
y'all going to jail that'd be a good
game show family welcome to family [ __ ]
that ain't bad as [ __ ] though if your
auntie is 34
and your niece is 22
yeah
oh man that physical challenge of me
crazy man remember that game show did
you guys watch a lot of game show
growing up family feuds
pyramid that was good
jeopardy you know [ __ ] with jeopardy
i know i was home at school when i was
watching prices right oh the price is
or you're just it was summertime
remember summertime just
every day it was the same yeah just
hanging
hanging just laying on the edge of the
couch yeah nothing new hot outside i
remember when my uh big old aunt june
came out oh yeah june sounds like you
know she's bigger than any neighbor
after a month yeah she was a big woman
30 days but she was she stayed and we
would have she would make me watch like
soap operas with her yeah yeah like days
of our lives all my children yeah
i used to watch one called santa
barbara's
with a s on it yeah
wow so it was more than one santa
barbara santa barbara's baby you look at
santa barbara's it was good let's see
the theme picture of it
in the 80s that's a real show so yeah it
was real it was real very good days of
our lives that's the only thing is there
asian soapbox like before and after some
growth hormones korean dramas
wait is there one guy in the back in
chocolate face she's real tan let's zoom
in oh no he's a venezuelan or something
he's the one latin on the show
yeah
you can't do that now that's too many
they have that on soap operas
no but there's like 20 people there theo
keeps
moving the bottom he's on the sun other
times
those are principal actors too huh
that's a martinez right there yeah
that's richie valen's brother right
there in the middle yeah
great movie dude
i watched it the other night so sad
great movie still has the same ending
they should change the ending
richie
great valenzuela is our dad's name
bob comes rolling into the [ __ ]
dancing great actor what was that dude's
name the pop he just died man no no no
no that guy didn't he didn't die what
movie oh la bomba oh la bombay oh word
yeah i thought you were talking about
selena yeah no different movies you
don't know where the lola also said
some sad ending they should change
the man who killed her yeah lou diamond
no no his brother who played while the
latin movie you got to have a sad indie
i know you noticed that
his brother was moralist something
moralistic morality yeah morales
great actor god he was good he just died
so good
i don't know what was the other one he
died with uh that they were in prison
blue diamonds not new diamond phillips
remember that guy no but uh phyllis is
not even mexican that's crazy thing what
is his filipino he's filipino no he was
in that movie i'm talking about where
they were in prison what was the name of
that prison boys
no no no no he was uh bad boys oh he was
sean penn he's in narcos too that's bob
right there no no they were getting no
no wasn't bad boys with sean penn that's
bob
i don't know what movie you're talking
about but jason's almost um american me
american me oh great remember american
eastside was not in that thing i'm too
young for all these [ __ ] movies
yeah these days you'd like american me
it's good yeah you haven't seen that no
no you gotta watch that yeah but y'all
need to get a few photos of panty bruh
something wrong with you i think yeah i
agree steve you're probably wearing
little panties huh no you put a thong
oh you're a straight old school boxer
guy
oh
remember those commercials can we see it
no you can't see it
with you
show them a little bit she's gonna show
your why
what you you
like everyone stand up and then put
their pants down yeah i'm down this is
scissor brothers
fart
we're having fun man no
[Laughter]
let's live a little please guys it'll be
fun live a little yeah let's just do it
we live it what are you working you know
what i see him go ahead and do it you
got it you do it for us let's see them
college draws doug i'm not looking yet
those old school just oh
it's coming out it's just his boxers man
why are y'all looking at that why we're
in old school boxers crazy this is just
like
it's almost like a kilt you know it's
like baggy boxes
yeah that's an asian guy wait wait is
that a catholic school girl's skirt
it's your turn no it's not it's your
turn
get us out of this gay world
stuff we'll reveal his on at the end
it's like a black hole that's just
pulling us in
i'm trying to i really am this guy's
great
what's up brown guy black guy asian guy
white guy
uh this is jeremy from riverside
california with my fly my heart
submission present huh this is my aunt
julie mm-hmm i mean i look like mom and
julie but this is my majority may look
like my uncle jerry but it's my aunt
julie
um
yeah she uh
born in brooklyn new york
obviously a real butch dyke
you know it's bd is the term it was cool
uh she used to be in the roller derby oh
[ __ ] oh okay used to fight men real men
not just men that
look like men looks like nick if you
didn't get this gig
that's [ __ ]
he also said she was 260 pounds had a
stroke and lost a lot of weight but i
did predict that you guys might say such
a thing just as proof i wrote them down
jokes you might possibly say
this looks like nick yeah there you go
he beat you to the point this guy this
guy just ate
good for you i said that at
11 22. time stamp that nick all right
good job buddy okay now we got to come
with it now we gotta go all right
damn uh but yeah that's uh that's just
truly but you said she's rad and she
used to roll her well she looks cool
yeah dude she like would you smash
oh
she looks like reggie light
this could be also a
young lady oh true would that mustache
out there no dude not with the stash
like facial hair is better than mine if
it is
dude this could easily and i don't want
i'm not saying that to be mean
i'm saying that because i could see
nick's surprising this with a woman at
this point hey what's up guys this is
josh and i've got a king interesting it
for you so theo i saw your twitter poll
and the results were 50 50. so i want to
know what you guys think
rocking perms
theo i'm growing a mullet till i see you
in the real ontario canada
thank you guys is that an earring i know
that's a hair but it's earring right
here he has some swag i like that yeah
he's got his own style and thank you sir
first of all i want to say that
for being yourself and being natural
yeah especially in canada yeah because
canada you get bored up there don't call
it you'll carve your dick off it's too
cold man oh you get so cold you should
dress like that this this was 50 50
should males get a perm
eleven thousand people voted dude a perm
what's wrong with it it's a skewed
sample size it's theo's audience which
is good yeah there's nothing wrong with
it i'm gonna i'm planning on perming the
back for christmas yeah very bad yeah
just the back you know get it curled up
nothing real heavy nothing i don't think
i would do like a wet curler you're
going to look like a 17th century judge
you're gonna look like you're gonna get
that george washington let's go
let's go curl over here you look like
pinky from friday i would maybe go a
little bit of a maybe a naturalizer or
something on it yeah put a little juice
get it wet show some samples
oh that's knuckle gladwell first of all
that dude was coming coming to america
what was that dude's name well i could
see you rocking that michael jackson
yeah ooh
baby look at cher oh damn
damn great actress i love that she snuck
in with all the guys because i put
famous man firms oh well ain't nothing
wrong with it oh sure damn perv is kind
of dope look at bradley cooper yeah look
at tom hanks my son has where's tom
hanks is that tom hanks thanks bro
that's tommy yeah
you gonna return your wiener at the
frickin front desk when i was back in
the day you know what i mean that's how
you did she bring that [ __ ] back deal
yeah ooh there you go tevin campbell
right there
who was that omarion yeah well it's fine
oh maureen should be pissed they name
that new strand after him
that's a little close yeah remember they
call it corona virus and corona bears
like [ __ ] ate [ __ ] yeah did they yeah
and then they change it to covet and
stay well up there in canada baby god
bless canada we'll be up there soon
because shit's going
we're kind of opening up huh canada is
kind of opening up the border you can
drive across it still it's the name
that's coming up i just did a house of
comedy and it was like where in uh
vancouver
and they just
went full capacity my thing is where's
all the dead people at bro
they're not letting them die but i'm
saying you know you every funeral every
uh it's not like you drive and pass you
and parliament and they packed up some
of you driving past graveyards and they
people's at the gate like we ain't got
no they gotta stack them you know
you know what i'm saying what is it
theo wants proof
my buddy actually my ex-roommate works
at a
mortuary
than what he said is he working overtime
he said yes a lot
half
more than
more than half to people it's like you
know four out of five is covet deaths
what's this guy want nick what's up king
and the sting listen
i saw the pumpkin video that got me
thinking
what's your take on throw pillows
i know eric griffin there's about to get
married
brandon you're already there we got
throw pillows on everything stephen
let me show you pillows on the couch yup
oh
head upstairs to the kids room
damn all the kids throw pillows that's
too many go in the daughter's room
more [ __ ] throws
daughter got him
have
let's leave it on the president on a
positive note
one throw pillow yeah okay
chin you've seen it let's say he sleeps
on a water bed you still got a water
bath are you shaving my bed now do you
have a water bed no it's a normal map
wouldn't have a water
[Laughter]
well just in case the hot plate
is king of the stink dude edit all this
out nick i swear to [ __ ] guys
steve puts a like a tube connected to
the water
so at night he can just go like this on
it
i don't
watermelon
today dude
[Applause]
no no you're not part of my team that
he's a part of my team
right kyle and he's a great guy thank
you okay thanks for tuning in guys to
another episode
yeah i love water mix from wisconsin
they wouldn't have water bands it'd just
been ice
igloo be a solid
it'd be a slushie you know what i mean
stevie you gonna dress up for the
holidays or what uh yeah i'm just trying
to see my mom who come in here and be a
little reindeer that'd be cute
you all want me to do
it
yeah we already have an elf costume
he should be like
a christmas tree
be a little changed
thanks for tuning in guys
[Applause]
theo's here i just wanted to be a little
reindeer man yeah rudolph i'll do it if
it's rudolph sure wasn't there one
no snowy yeah
[Laughter]
you can do this i like it i feel like
the reindeer would be chin that'd be
like that'd be the reindeer's name dude
my car is 50 psi in one of the towers we
don't have to do this right now nick so
we're about to wrap it up here buddy
we're about to wrap it up here buddy
is that an asian family in front of a
ranger can we see this again now right
now
let's wrap it up steve's the little one
that's like scary
oh yeah this is uh i think that this is
the chin's the tall one
chin's in the back and the
yellow ginger this is a korean version i
think of that movie powder all right
clean this thing the anti-asian podcast
that's the new name no no very
supportive because you no you said i was
that little girl dude i hate brendan
yeah there you go yeah i get the hate
there you go all right what we got
that's it man no shows we're not doing
none of that no shows oh yeah i got one
i'm in la jolla comedy store this
weekend oh my favorite i love that place
the best yeah dude that's gonna be fun i
know right that'd be so fun what are you
doing that's the best you're doing theo
and friends and i got a buzzer invited i
got oh i didn't think about that
of course you didn't that's exactly the
problem right there [ __ ] bro you
told me saturday it's wednesday it's
wednesday you told me saturday to shout
out see you and friends who are these
friends
i don't even have them yet yeah exactly
you want to come to a stats tv
yeah
wednesday night
when improv american improv
yeah i'll be there will you yeah
i could do five minutes like hey theo i
could do five minutes huh did you follow
me to gum you didn't lick though you
said i looked over and didn't really
like acknowledge i love it
check this out this is how i was invited
i'll be there
oh god
are you gonna ask like i don't know yes
[ __ ] yeah theo [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
you
you man
i'd love for you to be there yeah oh
really yeah really if you can get her
sting if you believe that you can
release no no we're not doing
disingenuous [ __ ]
i would love for you to be so improv
wednesday at coachella right well
that'll be our first time
first king of the sting people oh yeah
that's our first thing then if we just
said why don't you do that you don't you
never think about us over here well
you're busy [ __ ] you you know i know
you don't think he's [ __ ] he
don't even know how to get here every
time like he takes a new route
what is it
like hey how do i get to that thing that
i've been doing for a year how do i get
there
you didn't even think of something oh
look at this racist [ __ ] bring that back
up what was that what's going on here
nick
blind's fighting me
me and jeremiah will be at the souls
joel's comedy club january 8th in
jefferson pennsylvania is that like a
bowling team shirt like what a
strike
florida end of the month fort lauderdale
fort lauderdale florida december
no champion bowman coachella casino i'll
be at spotlight casino this saturday
night see you guys coachella gang now
that's a great show
[Music]
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan theo too yeah you
know how we do it so just tune in for
the laughs theo said that he was on his
way but ran out of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at paw
way
night only finished boys in the hallway
this ain't the greatest show on earth
and what you call that eric griffin
[Music]
he still need everything thick thick
they still got the bees in the trap
trapping
still the king in the sting so quit
asking if you know then you know it's a
cat's thing ball and chain hair swang
like the rat
[Music]
with the crew we got stevie weeby eric
griffin brendan do2 yeah you know how we
do it so just tune in for the laughs
theo said that he was on his way but ran
out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting
you